spider-man
this is mr. Baek Mysterio clam stock
chosen we need an Avenger
mr. stark trusted me I'm not gonna let
him down let's go save the world
spider-man
I've got this
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have a brand new spider-man far from
home TV spot trailer to breakdown in
this new TV spot we get a new better
look at some of the elementals a new
scene with Mysterio fighting an
elemental and a new scene with
spider-man this TV spot starts off with
a bit of a longer version of Peter
Parker meeting Quentin Beck or a
Mysterio for the very first time we
obviously know from other TV spots and
trailers that Mysterio shows up to help
save spider-man before he meets him and
we see in this TV spot Peters friends
watching the TV and clearly somebody on
TV whether it's a news reporter or
Mysterio doing an interview says that
his name is Mysterio so when Peter meets
him with shield he knows that he is this
supposed superhero but he doesn't know
who he actually is so this is where he
meets Quentin Beck for the first time
now of course this TV spot mentions Tony
Stark Nick Fury tells Peter Stark chose
you and then he says we need an Avenger
now of course an Avengers infinity war
Tony Stark made Peter Parker an Avenger
and in other trailers and TV spots we
hear Nick Fury say stark made you an
Avenger so again like I've mentioned
before everybody is expecting Peter to
step up because now he's not just the
friendly neighborhood spider-man now
he's an Avenger and then we get a better
look at some of the elementals and
something that I've noticed is that each
individual elemental is not that big
they're big but they're not ridiculously
huge however we do see one on the bridge
that is ridiculously huge if you compare
the sizes of Peter Parker and Mysterio
next to these individual elementals and
then next to this giant elemental you
can tell that it is much larger than the
normal ones and what I'm assuming this
is is a combination of all of the
elementals into one giant elemental you
have the sand one the water one and the
fire one creating this giant one and in
this TV spot we have a new scene with
Mysterio fighting this giant one and as
you can see this elemental is much
larger than all of the other ones that
we see Mysterio next to so this appears
to be all of the elementals that will be
in spider-man far from home combined
into one and then we have a new scene of
spider-man jumping off of happy Hogan's
plane where he just made his new suit to
go fight this giant elemental and
something interesting when he gem
out of the plane is that when he
releases his parachute it's the white
spider-man symbol not really sure if
there's a reason for his white
spider-man symbol but we also know that
it is on his new suit as well the black
and red suit that he makes in happy
Hogan's plane has a white spider-man
logo on it again not really sure if this
means anything but it does remind me of
Gwen Stacy who has been rumored to
possibly appear in spider-man far from
home but still I doubt it really has any
significance so that is it for this new
spider-man far from home TV spot let me
know what you think about this and let
me know if you think this giant
elemental is a combination of all of the
other elementals into one let me know
your thoughts on this and the comments
down below and a reminder about my
giveaway at the 450,000 subscriber mark
I'll be picking 3 winners and each will
get to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection to enter all
you have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
relations to your desperation to save
the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your